let's get to some more onset secrets and
this Gray's Anatomy reunion 13 years in
the making for the first time Catherine
Heigl and Ellen Pompeo are one-on-one
publicly dishing on Catherine's
controversial exit from the hit show
Gray's head and I felt I think it was
borrowed confidence I was so naive I got
onto my soapbox and I had some things to
say our first day back was Wednesday and
it was I'm going to keep saying this
because I hope It embarrasses them a
17-hour day really I think is cruel and
mean you were just a little early
because they came out with this thing
where everybody's got their own
megaphone it's called Twitter there were
certain boundaries and things that I was
not okay with being crossed that 40 was
freedom because I didn't have to be the
young sweet I don't know about the sweet
part I don't know that you were I
wouldn't describe you as sweet what are
you trying to say that's what people had
a problem with sweet they can handle
yeah strong they can't Catherine who
also criticized the writing race asked
to be let out of her contract early into
2010. she was being offered 12 million
dollar paychecks to do films I was like
up here you know in my headspace in my
gut in my mind in my life I was just
vibrating at way too high of a level of
anxiety other big reveal revering
varieties actors on Act down Ellen's
frustration with the direction of her
character before she stepped back from
the show in February I don't work here
anymore so you can call me Meredith I
think it's okay
or Meredith to
stop making bad decisions somehow
Meredith can't figure out how to make a
relationship work still after all this
time as for this iconic line so pick me
choose me
love me I fought that speech so hard I
can't beg a man on TV this is so
embarrassing so hard right and then it
turns out to be like one of the most
successful scenes or the most favorite
it was beautiful ever
[Music]